ipcc climate change report so 97 of
scientists agree that one yes the
science of democracy did we vote on do
we vote on gravity
we reach consensus
the way the scientists are trying to
consensus
with a consensus on newton's second law
here's the problem i want to know that's
free there's consensus no it's a hundred
percent because it's proof you can't
prove it here's the issue yeah yeah we
don't have an up or down vote on things
that could be you're not a scientist i
want to know what the three percent
believe you know why because usually the
three percent dissenting opinion against
the majority is the one that we should
listen to the most that's called the
scientific method so that's just wrong i
mean it's unless you have some
particular reason to believe that the
three percent is correct then the 97
percent is wrong there's no particular
reason that we should listen more to the
three percent than the 97 and even that
number is wrong it's really more like
99.8 and 0.2 percent uh but
that's just that's just a
that's a meaningless claim listen to the
minority more why well i mean okay
listen to what they're saying but why do
we give them more weight